oh yeah
focus
[Music]
it's cold and my name is george moats
and this is burger scholar session
outdoors the grilling episode for the
past four seasons we've preached the
virtues of cooking on a flat top but
nothing can replace the time-honored
tradition
of starting a fire and putting it out
with the fire department hang on
go get em boys nothing can replace the
time-honored tradition of cooking
outside on a flame grill but
it's not easy we're gonna make a
regional favorite of mine the sheboygan
bratburger that's right one of the
greatest examples of the broad burger in
the midwest is from a place called the
charcoal in south in sheboygan wisconsin
sheboygan is the epicenter of bratwurst
culture so much so they have a multi-day
festival called brat days which actually
was cancelled for 12 years due to
excessive rowdiness
yeah okay excessive rowdiness bratwursts
and beers sign me up the burger's very
simple all it is is a burger patty
cooked on a flame grill i got [ __ ]
more geese jesus
you hear that
i'm not feeding you geese [ __ ] off
it's a hamburger with a grilled
bratwurst on top of it it goes onto a
locally made hard roll and is served
with nothing more than pickles raw onion
rings mustard and a big wad of soft
wisconsin butter
[Music]
that's living are you ready for some
grilling secrets use a charcoal grill if
you're grilling with propane that's like
driving an automatic car you're like
not really paying attention you open the
grill you put the thing in there you
cook it you go to dinner so what okay if
you're grilling with charcoal
it's more like driving a stick shift
you're actually in there you're right in
the engine and you're moving stuff
around and making it happen you're
adjusting things and you want it to be
hotter so you do this you want to be
cooler you do that
that's grilling the charcoal method
lighting that people who are tried and
true outdoor grillers know and that's
the chimney method okay
this thing costs about 20 bucks or less
at the hardware store and it really is
nothing more than a metal tube with a
grain on the bottom all you do is shove
newspaper in the bottom of this thing
and put your charcoal on top and light
it no lighter fluid necessary
charcoal chimney
oh yeah oh yeah i've got a bratwurst for
you
not an ordinary bratwurst but two
okay the coals oh [ __ ] the coals are
ready whoa
okay before we get started you need to
understand my five commandments of
grilling
number one put the beer down
for the 15 minutes it takes to make
burger magic you need to focus focus
number two create zones on your grill by
pouring the charcoal onto one side only
that way you create a cool zone you can
slide your cooked burgers over to the
cool zone so it'll burn
all right [ __ ] all right yeah
if you guys know what i do i use a food
ring and form a patty inside the ring on
a piece of parchment paper you have to
have integrity in that burger to grill
properly number three don't get fancy
with your patties keep it simple people
add ice cubes sometimes ice cubes what
the [ __ ] no don't put ice cubes in your
burger why do you want water in your
burger do not put ice cubes in your
burger some people put butter in a
burger but that's only a cheat to hide
the fact they're using lean beef use
fatty beef so to make it a bra burger
you need bratwurst right but not just
any bratwurst we actually had shipped in
real wisconsin bratwurst from milwaukee
shout out to my buddy billy but they do
it charcoal in as they actually take the
bratwurst and they split it
down the middle casing comes off
goes on to the fire
patty goes on next to that
you might as well put some salt on there
and you're looking for a bra burger it's
going to be served on a fairly
hard
kaiser roll number four hot and fast
you want to have a nice hot grill so you
can sear that patty and lock in that fat
people ask me this question all the time
it's one of the oldest questions about
grilling when do you flip a burger a
friend of mine a certified aggies beef
once told me
you flip it when it's ready to flip
i asked him what that means he said the
burger will speak to you
he said okay now this is getting even
weirder what do i do next
he said you should look at the burger
[Music]
and when the burger starts to develop
liquid on the top of the patty that's
how you know it's ready to flip
the patty oh [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] that was
hot very hot
now if it's too hot this looks pretty
good if it's too hot you close the grill
it'll slow it down actually closing the
grill does help what's happening here
now is you have
airborne carbonic compounds
the fat is rendering from the burger
dropping onto
the fire and then igniting exploding
these little mini explosions are
happening there right now
look at that
oh [ __ ]
and when you reach your hand into a
grill if it's hot it will burn your hand
like that see that number five and one
of the most important rules of all don't
ever press down on that patty once you
flipped it if you do that you will
literally kill your burger you will
press all those glorious
juices and rendered fat out into the
fire the last place it should be it
should be in your belly if you have a
hot flame and good beef
it's going to cook pretty fast it has a
little bit of give to it it's a little
bit of give
it's probably
medium rare if it doesn't have a whole
lot of give at all you probably
overcooked it
this looks kind of perfect actually
right there and don't forget when you
take it off the grill
it's going to continue to cook like a
steak so i'm going to pull it off to the
cool side over here take a look at my
bratwurst that bratwurst looks
money
that's perfect it's so good so let's
prep the butt let's get the burger off
of here that's ready
onto the bun on top of that we're gonna
put the bratwurst put the bratwurst on
the bun
top of that
pickles
onions
got some mustard in the top of the bun
one last most important part is soft
wisconsin butter
oh yeah
that's amazing put on the bun
ah
[Music]
burger with the works look at that thing
oh
oh
[ __ ] yeah i'm the butter
oh wow
only wisconsin really thank you
wisconsin
thank you for this glorious burger thank
you
i'll see you next time hopefully i won't
need an icelandic itchy wool sweater to
make you a burger
[Music]
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here